hey everyone welcome back to brand new
video Rebecca on for honor again today
sadly there is no dev stream I believe
they're gonna be out for a couple weeks
as I said in my previous video but no
worries we are probably gonna be doing
at our cave quest video hopefully we can
get through it this one is gonna be
called the redacted test program
welcome to redacted test program you've
been selected for it redacted redacted
to learn the life of an assassin success
is crucial following these tests may
result in the damage to our redacted so
silent Laura here I can already tell
what's going on I haven't the slightest
clue what the [ __ ] I'm being told well
hopefully this would be a little bit
harder but not too hard to where I get
really pissed off with this so we'll
have to see and I'll see you when the
first game starts as usual we're gonna
be rocking with the jj-just not there's
nothing wrong gladiator but I like to
have JJ just in case we get into a
situation like this where we're
outnumbered we have a are Musa and issue
go key both whiffed meant maximum hell
decreased that they respawn after a
short time and she go keys attacks do
more damage and are all of our musha's
are uninterruptible but mine are all
unblockable with my revenge coming back
very quickly
[Music]
[Music]
okay so I didn't talk to that and I'm
gonna make it look like that was my
first try when you missed the seven
other times that I trying to figure how
to [ __ ] you do this okay game that's
alright game that's fine that's fine
this sort of a [ __ ] so that's not bad
you have to fight the are Musha first
kill him and then clap the chug okey
that's the best way I could they just do
it one at a time I suffer from bleed so
I'm bleeding the whole time interesting
I gained it health unsuccessful attack
so I should start attacking more but my
max help is increase that's good it
deals more damage when their HP is low
has a single consumable shield
[ __ ] warlord but has a health
his health regenerates constantly and
his attacks do us damage alright
hopefully we'll fight the warlord for I
hope guess we're not fighting warlord
first that's fine actually it's not even
a big shield
all right so yeah so basically my entire
health bar is full of bleed but I can
slowly get it back if I do damage that's
good you [ __ ] [ __ ] all right easy
it's to ease this [ __ ] easy mode bro
okay okay
okay that wasn't that bad
eliminate three samurai Templars we have
Nobu she with more damage and [ __ ] me
a so on I didn't want
I wrote you with uninterruptible yo
console bro and console be aware man
this is not gonna be fun and heavy
attacks blinding the opponent alright
but I have more revenge and my blocks do
more stamina damage oh my god they're
all gonna come at me at once oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
Bob get the [ __ ] out of my yard bro
what's up I wrote she's dead [ __ ] out
here oh I got kicked okay okay okay all
right
oh I love JJ no Reid oh alright I almost
at it I got the idea now um I think I'm
just gonna parry agree
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
easy it don't [ __ ] got here boy okay so
strategy for that one kill the dumb
[ __ ] kill no boo she get her dumb ass
out of here and then the rest are easy
cuz she does like triple the damage and
bleed you got me [ __ ] up
alright kill her first that's it who do
I fight now
ah fighting sorry baby I got his name
wrong was it is it Cesare
yeah Chester something like that I'm
fighting this sexy bastard
if that's the case this is an easy win
because I trained it oh no these [ __ ]
tea Ondina easy win nice guy legend oh
my god no way no it's the game wouldn't
probably wouldn't let me let him that's
probably a little bit unfair I tried to
allege him I'm alright I could be wrong
uhm maybe he wasn't at the point where I
thought he was gonna be alleged or the
game specifically put a wall there just
so that I couldn't legit
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's [ __ ] go get out my lobby all
right so the easy plan with that one is
basically if you're not confident when
finding a T on D this is gonna be a
little bit hard basically what you want
to do is blot if you're not confident
with the timings of T on D then just
pick just block him until he runs out of
stamina cuz he will just go full force
on you but if you are confident
throw some parries but don't follow up
with combos so for example with JJ after
you do a parry a light parry you follow
up the heavy but then after the heavy
you can do an unblockable heavy a follow
up light just don't just get the
confirmed damage and continue on with
the fight don't try to get extra is this
a solo flight you want to take your time
in real and read what he's gonna do most
of the time when he throws a light like
a dashing light or something like that
he will usually try to do a palm strike
so look out for that one yeah and as
always just remember to stay in the
house because you don't wanna get hit by
the archers we have boys that was at the
end we got to fight Cesare or Cesare a
whatever his actual name is I want to
see what I did get for this though I did
get the effect the Crimson conquest but
oh yes it's the emo version nice that's
good
anyway I appreciate y'all coming by if
you did stop by the video hopefully we
get some even harder stuff next week
I'll be interested to see this
definitely run in the back with JJ since
he's definitely one of the better
options in in arcade just because of his
high damage output in his ability to
survive ganks so with that hope you guys
do enjoy let me know if you guys were
able to beat this or how far you got
hurt this is too easy for you love to
know in the comments below the guys like
the V if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new I covered the informational
side of foreigner that being balanced
changes hero updates patch notes leaks
gameplay all that stuff like that within
for honor so we're gonna be kept up to
date just stay tuned to the channel my
two most recent videos would be
on-screen if you guys do want to check
that out but that guys have a great
yesterday thank for watching the video
and peace out
[Music]
you